The answer is it's the more peaked Gaussian.
That is somewhat counter-intuitive.
You'd think if this was your initial measurement probability
you really don't know where you are, and you should pick a very wide Gaussian.
But the truth is our new sigma-squared is obtained independent of the means.
It's this formula over here.
Now because both means are the same, this resolves to 1 over 2/σ².
That's the same as σ² over 2,
which means a new variance squared is half of the old one.
That makes it a narrower Gaussian,
so the green one here that's the most peaked is indeed the correct answer.
This is very counter-intuitive, but now we understand why.
I hope you feel comfortable with the fact that we have actually gotten
more information about the location, which is manifest by a more focused estimate.